So now that we've, we've got together all the criteria, and the, first order
logic expression of things, let's go back to Property 2 for a moment.
That requirement that the concrete implementation is consistent.
Recall that this means that all operations preserve invariants.
The relat, relevant invariant is that running total reflects the sum of
the transactions that have taken place.
So we have to make sure that each of the operations if that
invariant is true before hand, it's also we true, it is also true afterwards.
So the balance operation is not a problem because it doesn't effect the value if
the variables.
For the other two we would need an inductive argument that the invariant is
initially true and that deposits and withdrawals keep it true.
This intern relies on the fact that the sum operation can be defined in terms of
re, repeated additions and subtractions.